and now he moved to Georgia another
state that set an early voting record
for a midterm election more than 2
million early ballots were cast doubling
the old record that was set four years
ago the newest poll shows Republican
candidate for governor Brian Kemp with a
small lead over his Democratic rival
Stacey Abrams and mark Strassmann is at
Grady High School in Atlanta where
people are voting right now good morning
mark good morning when the doors first
opened here there were 200 people
standing in line the very first person
that got here 90 minutes early and
that's the kind of motivation both
candidates in this governor's race hope
for all day long a contentious race in
which each candidate has trashed the
other as the worst thing that could
happen to Georgia both candidates have
enlisted marquee names to stump for them
President Trump held a rally for
Republican Brian Kemp on Sunday and
former President Obama and Oprah Winfrey
stumped for Democrat Stacey Abrams last
week the former state lawmaker would
become the country's first female
african-american governor Abrams has
charged Kemp with voter suppression The
Associated Press reported more than
50,000 voters were stuck in a pending
status because their registration forms
did not identically match government
databases nearly 70% of those
registrants were African American Kemp's
office denies suppressing voters but on
Sunday his office accused Georgia's
Democratic Party with trying to hack the
state's voter registration system a move
Democrats called a Republican stunt
severe weather here especially in the
morning could affect turnout but as
close and contentious as this race has
been voters may be motivated to simply
ignore the weather and get to the polls
back to you guys all right mark thank
you